hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to life the game and II faint Oh
get oh [ __ ]
Oh Oh God no I no idea we're starting
from way in the beginning talk uh okay
why this doesn't seem like talking
there's more like singing I got a
protest at this because I'm pretty sure
I know what talking is all about kids
under get you for a living
oh hell are you talking about you baby
yeah I did it
did I progressed to adulthood Oh t plus
5 is 17 Oh God
square root of 9 3 it's 20 got it got it
yeah who's puberty holy [ __ ] Oh God
you're not supposed to pop this is how
you get acne scars now were you supposed
to be doing no no I don't make my
mistakes I got acne scars because I
popped my skewers oh this poor son of a
[ __ ] oh okay I guess we're okay then
never mind then Oh date oh okay Oh swipe
oh yeah sure what what you were always
attractive dangerous chicks this time
you went far and found the next seven
days and oh oh okay but she looked okay
uh yeah oh my god kitten seeing that old
lady's so happy accompanied only by a
cute little feline creature made you get
a tiny cat too today you live alone with
16 and a half cats and spend 18 hours a
day catering to their routine okay I'll
play your way game yeah she looks nice
Zoidberg why not oh okay that's
acceptable apparently oh cool huh boink
boink boink going going going
Oh killing it in turn oh that doesn't
seem good make coffee uh get married
alright hurry we're rushing in a little
bit to this I don't know if I want to do
all this what does this do
Oh shoes Oh get kids well didn't we skip
a step here
whoa all [ __ ] goddamnit we're getting
what well [ __ ]
okay no the car I need it goddamn a car
get out of there ya know anything but
I'm really depressed about it okay good
life crisis still the [ __ ] I thought I
oh I bought everything oh I'm not
supposed to buy everything okay new car
weights
I want that speedo and I want that giant
jalapeno for some reason hey I have abs
really oh [ __ ]
what do I do in the fire in the fire but
put him in the fire but your first day
as a babysitter for your oldest daughter
you managed to elect to give the kid
poison the second and set the third kid
on fire
good job now it's time to move on to our
time home to live up your few remaining
days filled with sadness and loneliness
that's what I already planned oh okay
I was getting a little - crisis II
grandchildren okay what am i what am i
what am I doing here just not letting
them kill themselves cuz oh my god they
real they real this is like daddy's home
oh god oh god oh god I'm juggling no I
put them towards the fire holy [ __ ]
uh-huh okay stay healthy how I don't
know god I'm very slow at this why am i
oh geez walkush well up and over up and
or [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah that's not gonna
cut it
alright titty sprinkles god damn it
burns it's an old man [ __ ] this [ __ ] ah
I can't do you anymore I've lost all
control of my bowels my bladder doesn't
function as a urinary tract it's not
just a superhighway for infection
[ __ ]
chassé Lee who needs this pill anyway is
what you said a day before you went in a
drug withdrawal and slipped into a coma
that you never recovered room okay then
nice and easy we got all the time in the
world look nice and easy like a steady
old man should be steady like a fox
stuck
cool wave I'm actually just kind of slow
and careful about it's pretty yay I die
wait what the [ __ ]
hang on a tick here hold hold your tits
what them oh [ __ ] oh but why do Oh God
it is said that your life flashes before
your eyes just before you die that is
true
it's called life terry pratchett
oh-oh-oh
we're done Wow well that was life
cool huh glad we did that together thank
you I guess we're done here
there's a sequel to this game called
afterlife the game so I guess I'll be
playing that one but have a lovely day I
love you ah